today on the matt walsh show if you were
expecting the media to back away from
race hoaxes and shame after the jesse
smilet verdict think again yesterday
espn tried to resurrect the bubba
wallace noose fable also is amazon to
blame for the workers who died when a
tornado hit their factory on saturday
and uh you've heard about the male
swimmer crushing the female competition
at the college level today we'll
actually watch one of those races to see
for ourselves what a farce it all is
plus the the head of the nih breaks into
song during a press conference and in
the daily cancellation we'll deal with
the controversy surrounding comments
that ben shapiro's sister made about
madonna am i going to cancel a member of
the shapiro family today we'll talk
about that and much more on that wall
show
[Applause]
[Music]
as an increasing number of companies
fall all over themselves trying to
appeal to the radical left wouldn't it
be nice to find one that supports you
and your values well charity mobile is
that company training mobile is the
pro-life phone company they partner with
you to automatically support the
pro-life pro family charity of your
choice with five percent of your monthly
plan price and they've sent millions of
dollars to charities so far
and there are a lot of other perks that
you get with this uh with this service
as well new activations and eligible
accounts get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping when you
mention offer code walsh and they also
make it really easy to switch you can
keep your existing phone you may even be
able to keep uh rather keep your
existing phone number and you may be
able to keep your existing phone and
unless you want a new phone there's no
problem there either charity mobile has
a variety of options from basic flip
phones and low cost smartphones to the
latest 5g phones and i also love that
they have
special flip phones and other kinds of
phones with parental controls built in
so that if you do want to get your kid a
phone so they can you know get in
contact with you
then you don't have to also give them
access to the internet so i would very
much recommend that there are no
contract contracts no termination fees
and no risk with a 30 day guarantee
switch to charity mobile and support the
causes you care about call them at
1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com and mention offer code
walsh so people often ask me you know
why i am so stubborn and hard-headed and
close-minded refusing to admit when i'm
wrong refusing to apologize doubling
down when people are upset at me and
then tripling down when they're mad that
i doubled down the answer is that i'm
just kind of a jerk frankly i mean
that's the answer but also because
although maybe not everyone can or
should operate this way we all have
different personalities
some of us need to
because this is the kind of thing we're
up against we cannot all be
equivocators and compromisers while we
face an ideological opponent who stands
firm in his position no matter what
regardless of the facts regardless of
anything
some of us have to be a bit obstinate
headstrong or else we'll all be blown
around by the breeze like little leaves
and twigs
a perfect example of the left
stubbornness which uh calls for for a
proportional response i think is this
it's been less than a week since the
justice millett verdict when the left
and the media were
all you would think humiliated after the
hoax they promoted was revealed as a
hoax you might assume that they would
want to crawl into a hole for a while
lick their wounds hide their faces and
certainly steer plenty clear of anything
else that looks like it might be a race
hoax
but that's just not how they roll and so
yesterday espn with timing that is not a
coincidence
decided to air a special on the bubba
wallace story
now you remember that bubba wallace was
the black nascar driver who claimed that
somebody hung a noose in his garage last
year
nascar rallied around him the media ate
the story up and it all culminated in
the dramatic display of all of the
drivers of talladega marching around the
track with bubba wallace in a show of
solidarity and they all gave him hugs
and they were all crying
of course there's one really important
detail about that noose quote unquote
which is that it was not a noose
it was a rope that you used to close the
garage door
a garage door pull as you know we call
it
anyone who's ever been in a garage might
be familiar with these contraptions
they're just like ropes right that's why
they're hanging that's why it's
interestingly enough hanging from the
garage door you might wonder oh why is
that rope on the garage door oh because
when you pull it
the door goes down wow
nascar drivers who spend many hours in
garages are certainly familiar with with
these things they see them all the time
but even if bubba wallace and everybody
else at the speedway that day had
suffered amnesia and forgotten about the
existence of garage door pulls
they still could have easily figured out
whether the rope was meant to be some
kind of racist message to bubba wallace
there there are security cameras all
over the place
as some of us pointed out when this
story was first reported
well there are security cameras so
couldn't you just
quite easy to find out what's going on
simply go back and check the footage and
see how long the rope has been there if
it's been there for longer than a day or
two that means that it could not have
been targeted at bubba at bubbus millet
bubba wallace sorry because nobody would
have known prior to that point that
wallace would be assigned to that garage
so that's all you got to do
security cameras just look at them look
at the footage it'd take like 10 minutes
now as it happens the fbi showed up with
15 agents to investigate the rope
and they did exactly that they checked
the tape
and when they did they discovered that
it had been there since the previous
year
for months it had been hanging there and
nobody thought anything of it
did we need 15 fbi agents to look at the
footage and discover this is there a
reason why nascar couldn't have done
this themselves immediately before
running out to the public and telling
everyone that there's a suspected
potential noose-like structure in
bubba's garage
the answer to both is no
well the real answer is no they didn't
need the fbi agents they could have
checked themselves but they preferred
the narrative of the racist noose and so
they ran with it until they could run no
longer
or you thought they could run no longer
but here they were last night on espn
trotting this thing out again a year
later
let's watch some of this clip here
i just wanted to stand with him during
the national anthem to show my support
for him and was appalled by
what i had learned
and then as drivers got involved i think
crew members team managers team owners
it really started to snowball within a
very short period of time
[Music]
the most
incredible
non-competitive moment in sports i'd
ever seen
that moment i could feel the weight of
that moment and i think we all did as we
were walking
yes it may have been
one of the most incredible moments in
sports never in history
never the history of sports has there
been such pageantry and emotion
surrounding a garage door
this was quite easily i think we could
say this right
quite easily the most dramatic garage
door related sports moment in world
history
but i'm not sure if that's anything to
brag about necessarily
and just because i'm a glutton for
punishment let's keep watching a little
bit of this clip here
i
get out of the car
i look back
and i was like holy sh it's a whole
garage
the whole garage
that's when i lost it
in the midst of all the turmoil
that was going on in the world
with the black and white the hatred and
everything that was going on
the entire nascar family
rally behind my son
[Music]
very inspiring um now just to remind you
you know again
it was not a news
so it was 100 not any kind of racist
attack at all
it was just a rope with a loop on it so
you could grab hold of it to pull the
door closed
um and and by the way that's also how we
know it's not a noose
because a noose and i know like this
people on the left
they don't spend a lot of time outdoors
they probably don't do a lot of fishing
or you know that kind of thing so
they're not familiar with tying knots
but i can tell you that not every knot
is a noose
in fact most of them aren't
only one knot is a noose and it's a
noose and all the others are different
kinds of knots and but they might look
kind of similar because i know again
if you don't spend a lot of time outside
you and you maybe and all you do is
watch corporate media you see a rope
and maybe you just start breaking down
in tears because you think well why else
would that rope be there except to hang
somebody
uh but a new system has a particular
application and so one one of the like
by definition a noose when you pull on
the loop
it constricts
because that's that's why that's what
it's made to do that's what makes it a
new so if you pull on the loop and it
does not constrict then it's not a noose
and so since this thing was hanging
there as a garage door for since since
the previous october we could probably
assume that it was not constricting when
you pulled on it because i mean it would
like every time you try to shut the
garage door it would break your hand
and so i'm going to assume that that had
not been there for months where every
time you uh you shut the garage door
just everyone's getting their hand
broken and no one thinks to change the
knot so i'm assuming that's not the case
which means that it was just a it was a
knot that did not constrict it's not a
noose
so this in other words this was not a
makeshift gallows that had been set up
to perform executions before uh you know
before the race we know all of this now
i mean any intelligent person knew at
the moment they heard about the story
even before the fbi brain trust
confirmed it but now even the dumbest
among us knows it
and still espn aired the special
they report they reported themselves
last year that the fbi confirmed it was
not a hate crime and yet here they are
you thought the media would be
embarrassed by jesse smallett instead
they're saying oh yeah you think we're
embarrassed by that we'll take this
here's an emotional documentary about a
black guy who was afraid of his garage
door
so this is the uh this is the double
down
it's also as i've been explaining for
the last few weeks the reality curation
they are shaping the way people view
reality
the actual details don't matter
in fact in fact the whole idea that
nooses are racist symbols
is itself a part of that reality
curation nooses actual nooses like real
nooses have been used for thousands of
years for different applications but yes
often to perform executions many
thousands of people or millions
of all different races have died that
way through the course of human history
many of them have been convicted
criminals in some cases they are
unjustly lynched by violent mobs but
whoever decided that the noose this this
like universal object
is a symbol of special significance to
black people
when when did that start
well the media decided that
they decided it some time ago and and
they've now turned it into a reality
through one hoax after another
they've been so successful in
constructing this reality that even
people on the right who are skeptical of
the individual noose hoaxes still don't
stop to question why we're pretending
that the noose is a racist symbol in the
first place
that's the power of the false reality
that the left has constructed
and which permeates and intrudes into
the lives of people who would otherwise
know better
so it's a very unique situation in
modern times they've always they've
always been liars and propagandists in
the world but never with such immediate
and all-encompassing access to so many
people
and so with this ability to
fundamentally reshape how we look at the
world
which is all the more reason to remain
vigilant and skeptical and if we stand
in the truth
to stand there stubbornly
at least as stubborn as the liars are
with their lies
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
if you got guests coming over for
christmas um you know one one of the
great sins i think as a host is to not
have anywhere
comfortable for your guests to sleep you
wanna make sure they have they have a
comfortable spot to sleep and nothing
wrong with putting guests on a on a
couch i never mind sleeping on the couch
taking the couch if i'm staying at
someone's house but
make sure it's a comfortable couch and
it will be if you get an all-form couch
what makes an all-form sofa really cool
well for starters it's the easiest way
you can customize a sofa using premium
materials and at a fraction of the cost
of traditional stores you can pick your
fabric the sofa color the color of the
legs sofa size everything is customized
they've got arm chairs and love seats
all the way up to an eight-seat
sectional so there's something for
everybody and you can always start small
and buy more seats later on if you want
and so your all forms sofa can grow and
change if you wanted to all form sofas
are also delivered directly to your door
in the past if you wanted to order a
sofa you would need to hire somebody to
come and assemble it in your home or
break your back trying to put it
together yourself all form has simple
quick assembly
no tools are needed at all and if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds a little risky you don't
need to worry you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it that's more than
three months and if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free and give you
a full refund they also have a forever
warranty literally forever on this
warranty and all form is offering 20 off
all orders for our listeners at
allforum.comwalsh to find the perfect
sofa check out allform.com
walsh uh a couple quick notes here about
uh my best-selling children's book
johnny the walrus really important first
of all and and i think this is i think
this is brilliant i think this is great
but i've had uh some people reach out to
me
saying that they want
to donate the books to uh their local
schools
especially their local elementary
schools i had once
started with one parent group in
southern california
and uh what they want to do is get a
bunch of the books and then buy a bunch
of boxes and donate them to
very generously and i think that those
elementary schools down there in
southern california will be very very
grateful uh for these books
and if you i think it's a great idea i
plan on doing that myself i'm going to
make some um
this is good news for the
schools around here in nashville but i
plan on making some very generous
donations myself of this book um to the
schools around here so if you want to do
that if you want to buy the books in
bulk you can go to bulkbooks.com
and then search for johnny the walrus
and then you get the discount buying in
bulk
but i'll tell you one place that you
cannot go to get johnny the walrus
unfortunately i mean you can go to
amazon and you can still find it there
you won't find it listed as an lgbt book
because of homophobia and gay erasure
and it was it was taken off but it's
still there you can go to
johnnywalrus.com but you cannot go to
target because the book has been taken
off of target
and they took it off at some point last
week like late last week
they
got rid of johnny the walrus
and we've been asking
i think it's a fair question
yeah i mean it's they can decide what
books they're gonna sell but
i think we have a right to know why they
took the book down
it was this was a decision made by
someone what was your reason
and so we have been contacting target
reaching out to them just saying why
would you take down this book written by
a best-selling lgbt author
this delightful book about a young boy
pretending to be a walrus
it's
are we are are you saying that this is
prohibited now that you're not going to
sell books about children uh pretending
to be different things
books of fantasy and imagination that's
that's no longer allowed at target is
that what you're saying
really fair question we've been asking
them can't get an answer uh if you want
to ask target then i would very much
encourage you to do that you can um one
thing you can do is contact them on
on twitter it's
at ask target
and that seems to be their account that
usually will respond to consumer
questions and complaints
and uh but they haven't responded to me
yet
so i don't know if it's
from target this this could once again
be homophobia rearing its ugly head
where they're saying
oh i don't want to talk to the to the
number one best-selling most revered
lgbt author in the country so this might
be something targeted at me you might
have more luck
um i don't know but if you want to do me
a favor do us all a favor really
and find out why target took john the
walrus stone
um
free johnny hashtag end
walrus phobia
all right
so let's start
here jen posaki was uh asked about the
sky high inflation she's another one
who's not
very not very forthcoming with answers
she doesn't like answering a lot of
questions just like target apparently
doesn't but uh she did have an answer
finally on this like who's who is to
blame for the fact that it costs so much
money when you go to the grocery store
uh if you want to buy you know some
ground beef or something costs a lot of
money and she says well it's not our
fault
this is this is all the fault of big
meat big meat is to blame let's listen
there are several progressive groups and
lawmakers who are
increasingly vocalizing the idea that
inflation high inflation is being driven
by corporate greed
including companies with high profits
some of whom have met at the white house
with the president in recent months um
does the president endorse that idea
does he think the corporate greed is a
big driver of inflation right now well i
think that the president thinks the way
people across the country american
families
digest inflation is by price increases
and if you look at industry to industry
it's a little different so for example
the president the secretary of
agriculture have both spoken to what
we've seen as the greed of meat
conglomerates that is an area where
people go to the grocery store and
they're trying to buy a pound of meat
two pounds of meat 10 pounds of meat
it is the prices are higher that is in
his view
and the view of our secretary of
agriculture because of you could call it
corporate greed short you could call it
uh jacking up prices uh
during a pandemic
there are other areas where we've seen
increases
because of supply chain issues and we're
seeing those increases around the world
as it relates to gas prices uh oil
supply and things along those lines so i
would say there are some areas where we
have seen uh corporations benefit profit
from the pandemic and
and certainly the president would agree
with that component i don't know the
full context of all of their remarks
uh it's uh
no it's various things it's the greed of
meat conglomerates it's supply chain
issues it's uh
it's the inflation fairy and she's
invisible and she goes to the grocery
store she sprinkles inflation dust over
all the the food that happens too the
point is it's it's everybody's fault but
ours
if this is the greed of uh big meat of
the the giant shadowy meat conglomerates
then why did they just start getting
greedy
once
president biden took office
what's up with that
especially when president by the
democrat party they're supposed to be
the uh
the corporate
slayers right they're going after and
they're taking down the big corporations
so
i mean that's kind of odd
that in tandem with biden taking office
that's when coincidentally all of a
sudden the uh the big meat conglomerates
they've decided to get greedy
so what what has happened
in the last year
to make uh big meat so greedy
big meat was was was not as greedy
before and now they are biden takes
office and they get greedy why is that
of course the excuse doesn't make any
sense at all because that's exactly what
it is it's an excuse here's another
thing that that doesn't make any sense
but i have to show you this
um
i don't have to but i'm going to and
we're trying to get through this
together as much as we can
the director of the nih francis collins
is stepping down
and he gave his last
address i guess to the public this is
supposed to be sort of a
press conference an address to the
public talking about
the pandemic talking about
and his last act
was this listen
[Music]
somewhere
past the pandemic
when
we're
free
there's a
life i remember
full of activity
somewhere
past the pandemic
masks will
come off
no
more
need for a nose swab
every time
we cough
okay
just don't pause it because we might go
back to it
if you feel like if you guys feel like
you need to hear more of that
i don't know i was kind of getting into
it
let's just play a little bit more i want
to hear a little bit more of this song
just play a little bit more
as we are gathered here today
covid's toll has hit and sent us reeling
[Applause]
but partners like the ones right here
will help to make the pathway clear to
find
it true okay now we're going to rewind
it and watch the whole thing again but
this time i want you to focus on the uh
sign language interpreter because that's
a whole other no i'm kidding we're not
actually going to play it but that's a
whole different experience when you're
watching the sign language interpreter
who you can tell is painfully
embarrassed but she she has to just roll
with it
that's that's not uh i i swear to you
when i first saw this
on online i thought is this like a deep
fake thing this has got to be a joke
this cannot be real
i know we've seen this all over tick
tock people love singing about
kovid for some reason but there's no way
that francis collins the director of the
nhs but no this is real he actually did
that that that is a thing that happened
and this this this shows you it shows
you a lot of things one is um
even before he broke out into song this
was the case that we see how
when people
get into a bureaucracy they become
bureaucrats
it has this effect of of lessening them
you know
and that's really a shame with francis
collins because he he in fact is a
brilliant scientist he was one of the
guys who sequenced the human genome i
mean he's one of the he's he's a great
brilliant scientist
but now this is what he has become
as a bureaucrat
my god
and we can we can laugh
in a cringy awkward way at that because
what else are you going to do
but there is also something kind of
sinister about it
because what's it's it's this this
fanciful song about somewhere past the
pandemic everything will be good again
you could take the masks off
but just like we talk about somewhere
over the rainbow even in wizard of oz
and the place over the rainbow doesn't
really exist it's all a dream in the end
it's a bait and switch
which always bothered me even when i was
a kid i first saw that movie um so it's
it's not real is the point the place
over the rainbow is everything is great
it's but it's it's your it's in your
imagination it's in your dreams it's not
a real place
and that's
basically what we're being told there
and this thing goes from awkward to
creepy when you think of it that way
what we're being told by the nih is that
the place past the pandemic it's like
the place over the rainbow in that it
doesn't exist because we're never going
to be past this well this is how it's
going to be forever you're never taking
the mask off
if you live in a place where you still
have to wear it
you're never taking it off if you're in
california where i just was for a few
days suffering through uh you're never
taking the mask off
so that's the real message past the
pandemic is a is a fantasy
but but but keep dreaming about it keep
thinking about it
and keep cooperating and obeying
and maybe one day
this this far-off fantasy will come to
fruition
that's the real message of the song
all right let's um
let's go here amazon i just i wanted to
talk about this briefly amazon is coming
under fire after a number of employees
were killed during the deadly tornadoes
on saturday
and this was at a warehouse in illinois
i think that i think was six people were
killed i believe
and um and then there was a different
not an amazon factor but a different
factor in kentucky where dozens and
dozens of people were killed
and especially amazon is getting
criticism for whatever reason i i
haven't heard as much
uh criticism directed at whatever
company runs the factory where those
people are killed but
a lot of the criticism seems to seem as
a center around the fact that amazon
wouldn't let employees leave during the
storm
you've probably seen that headline
all over the place
they weren't allowed to leave they had
to stay also i've seen people going
after amazon for forcing employees to
come to work even though there were
tornadoes in the forecast as i saw
somebody phrase it on twitter
so i want to touch on these two things
quickly i'm not one to defend amazon
um and i don't i don't really care if
people are attacking amazon doesn't
doesn't personally offend me in any way
but i also i hate nonsense
and there's a whole lot of nonsense
related to this situation
and i so i want to explain that
first of all
was was amazon right
in not allowing their employees to leave
uh once the tornado hit once there was a
tornado warning was that the right thing
to do to force employees to stay there
yes
absolutely
and it's obviously a great tragedy that
people ended up dying
but it was the right thing to do to make
them stay
because that is anyone who's lived in
the midwest anyone who's lived in a
tornado prone area knows this this is
standard procedure when you get a
tornado warning in fact now you you get
them on your phone you get the alert and
what does the phone tell you what is the
weather report everyone tells you stay
where you are
if you're in a building find the safest
place in that building but what you
don't do is leave of course amazon
wasn't going to send people to their
cars out on the road when there's a
tornado out there the car is the worst
place you could be
and if you didn't know this then this is
a
a useful segment right now on the show
maybe it'll save your life one day the
last thing you want to do this is not
like an action movie where you get into
your car you try to outrun the tornado
the worst place you could be is a car
because there's falling limbs there's
debris everything you're very much
exposed if the tornado goes anywhere
near you i mean you're you're in as far
as the tornado is concerned uh you're in
a very light
uh you know you might as well be a
ragdoll that's gonna get tossed around
by the storm
so you don't go
in your car you find a solid structure
the most solid you can find if you're in
a building you find the safest place in
that building last year my wife was out
grocery shopping and there was suddenly
a tornado warning and they told everyone
don't leave you stay in the grocery
store
now if my wife had made a run for it i
don't think they would have shot her to
make her stay but
they said don't leave stay here
because we're not going to send you all
out to the parking lot into your cars to
make a run for it if amazon had said to
their employees there's a tornado
warning everyone run to your cars and
get out
and then six people have died or more
and there could have been a lot more
now they're really liable
because they went against standard
safety protocols when it comes to
tornadoes which again the standard
protocol is
stay where you are hunker down
unless you're in a car that's the only
time you're supposed to leave if you're
in a car try to park somewhere and get
to a structure if you can
um
and then the second thing about well
there were tornadoes in the forecast and
they had their employees come to work
anyway
again if you live in a tornado prone
area you already know this
there are tornadoes potentially in the
forecast like 200 days of the year
a tornado watch just means that the the
that the atmospheric conditions are such
that there could be tornadoes but you
can't shut down work every time
there's there could potentially be a
tornado
then if you live in in some of these if
you live in kansas or something you'll
never go to work because it's almost
every day there's a potential
especially in the summer
so that's all that it means is there's
tornadoes in the forecast it just means
that like there could be somewhere
tornado or maybe not because that those
those are the weather conditions
but you still basically go about your
day under a tornado watch tornado
warning means okay now we've seen a
funnel cloud it's out there but it's too
late
to you know evacuate the town or
something you got to hunker down there's
a reason why you don't hear about
towns evacuating
in the lead up toward tornado like they
do with hurricanes because tornadoes are
different than hurricanes hurricanes are
these big lumbering things that start
out there
over over the ocean and you could see
them literally from a thousand miles
away and the only speculation is what
course they'll take and how strong the
winds will be by the time they get to
you but as it gets closer and closer you
get a better idea and then at a certain
point you really know with fair amount
of certainty where it's gonna land and
basically how strong it will be and so
then you can you can evacuate far ahead
of time you can't do the tornadoes
that's what makes tornadoes so uniquely
dangerous
is that all you know is that well there
could be and then and then it's here and
that's it
and once it's here it's too late to
leave you stay you hunkered up
so i don't think it's fair to hit amazon
on either of those points
um
but
being that they were in a relatively
tornado prone area
if they didn't have any kind of shelter
within the building
then i think you i think that you can
hold them at fault for that
i think they claim that they did have a
shelter but some of the employees chose
not to enter the shelter for whatever
reason i don't know if that's true or
not but if they didn't have a shelter
that's a problem but these other things
i wouldn't i wouldn't go after them for
that i think these are these are people
who don't understand tornadoes or how
they work and so that's how they work
all right here is uh
okay i got to play this for you this is
an interesting and instructive video
leah thomas quote unquote leah
thomas
uh is the male swimmer
at university of pennsylvania
you remember this story we've talked
about the last you know over the last
week
uh he was
i i i don't know if he was a he wasn't i
don't think he qualified as necessarily
a top male athlete as as a swimmer for
the first three years of his college
career but he was he was certainly
competitive he was a competitive male
athlete as a swimmer for three years in
his final year
he says you know what
turns out i'm a woman and he decides to
go over and compete against the women
and now he's dominating the competition
dominating them
because he was competitive this is
different from some of these other cases
where you've got very mediocre male
athletes or or poor male athletes who
come over to the female side and they
win
pretty handily but it's not the same
level of domination
so we could talk about that i mean we
could talk about how he's dominating the
competition i can tell you that for
example in one of his recent meets
he he finished first and second place
was 40 seconds behind him
now in terms of swimming in terms of a
race
unless it's a marathon
40 seconds might as well be four months
that's how big the gap is but we could
talk about that intellectually we could
we could think about it intellectually
i think to see it is a whole different
matter
so i want to play this is this is a
recent race
and i'll have to narrate it a little bit
and if you're watching on audio then
maybe go dailywire.com or go to youtube
and if you when you get a chance to see
this footage for yourself because you
have to see this
so let's play this this was a recent
race and you see um
the arrow there okay kind of the middle
lane there's the arrow that is leah
thomas okay he's finished
and listen
do you hear anybody cheering in the
crowd they're not cheering he finished
he won
so middle lane there where the arrow was
he's done
and now he's waiting now here's we see
some some uh some female competitors
they're coming up to the wall
is that are they gonna be second uh no
they still have a whole other lap to go
and we've got someone else some people
on the far lane there are are they
coming is that going to be second
are they second place
uh no not second we still haven't got
the second place
they've got a whole other lap to go okay
now finally we get second place there is
and listen listen to this
oh don't listen okay we cut it off uh
the crowd starts cheering for that
person because they're not the crowd
knows
the crowd knows the score
leah thomas finishes
um
i think that you may have heard one
person clapping i don't know if that's
someone in his family
and then the the the real winner
finishes and then you get the the crowd
cheering
that's what 40 seconds looks like
in a race
as i said it may have well been four
months
thomas could have gotten out of the
track
and started eating a snack or something
he could have got out of the track got a
hot pocket went to a microwave heated it
up started eating it and then come back
and watch the rest of the race and then
he would have seen second place
that's how far ahead he was
that is the difference biologically
between men and women
that's the advantage that your bile that
your
physiology gives you
if you're a male
it is an insurmountable advantage
you think any of those women there
as as talented as they may be against
women
what are they going to do to shave 40
seconds off their time
maybe if they start taking
steroids like but even then probably not
because he's on steroids that's the
thing when you're a male
racing against women
it is
it's it's cheating you have a chemical
advantage very similar to the advantage
that someone with performance-enhancing
drugs has
it's a similar advantage
you have similar
chemicals coursing through your veins
except except naturally rather than
artificially even if you can diminish
those chemicals because you're
suppressing hormones or whatever you're
taking estrogen
you still have all of the other
advantages
that come with being a male that give
you a 40 second
head start
total farce total joke
and yet
yeah we could appreciate the crowd uh
for cheering
for the right winner
but they still held the race
and all those you know the parents came
and they watched
as long as you're
doing the race and participating in it
then you are participating in this farce
you're propping it up you're supporting
it
you know we need more than people kind
of passive aggressively not
cheering for thomas
that's good but we need a lot more than
that
there need to be there need to be
protests there need to be female
athletes
coming together
and and agreeing that they're not going
to participate in races where he's there
you do that and maybe we'll start seeing
some change maybe
um
all right one other thing this is from
the daily callers the superstar billy
eilish opened up about how she started
watching porn at around the age of 11
and said she feels watching it has
destroyed her brain
a 19 year old singer shared during an
appearance on the howard stern show
as a woman i think porn is a disgrace i
used to watch a lot of porn to be honest
i started watching porn when i was like
11. i think it really destroyed my brain
i feel incredibly devastated that i was
exposed to so much porn
i'm so angry that porn is so loved and
i'm so angry at myself for thinking that
it was okay
the way that vaginas look in porn is
effing crazy no vaginas look like that
women's bodies don't look like that we
don't come like that uh the first few
times i had sex i was not saying no to
things that were not good
it was because i thought that's what i
was supposed to be attracted to
okay i mean this is
on one hand if you want to look at from
the pessimistic angle it's uh it is
frustrating
that some of us have been saying this
about pornography for uh
for years
and we've been shouted down and mocked
and everything oh it's with port it's
just it's just images on a screen what's
the big deal
it's just a fantasy oh what do you mean
porn harms harms harms women oh that's
silly that's ridiculous
um and now when a 19 year old pop star
starts saying it people take it a little
bit more seriously that's a pessimistic
angle of it but
you know
whoever the source needs to be i'm glad
that it's that that this is happening
and she's not the first one we this is
this in fact is what we need we need
people yeah i mean someone like me i can
sit here all day and talk about that and
say what what a harm
um it is
but to a certain extent it's always
going to be dismissed as
religious puritanism or whatever
but billy eilish as far as i know
i'm assumed i could be wrong i'm
assuming not a not a devout christian
and she's telling you her own experience
she's not alone in this
in fact there's a there's a whole
generation of people if you would listen
to them
people about billy eilish's age
just now becoming adults
and they grew up with this stuff they
are the first generation that grew up
with online porn and i don't want to
hear anything from older people about oh
what are you talking about when i was a
kid there was a playboy under my dad's
mattress that whole canard
i mean if your dad had pornography under
his mattress and he was allowing you to
access it then your dad was a creep and
i'm sorry about that
but that is nothing like this
okay magazines
magazine images
on pieces of paper
nothing like the the permeation of
hardcore porn that children young
children i mean she says at age 11 she
started looking at this stuff
so these are pre-pubescent kids she says
it destroyed her brain she's right
now fortunately the damage is not
permanent there's a way to
to overcome it i think
but there are certain effects that will
linger forever because this is during
your formative years
this is before puberty
um your idea of human sexuality is very
much shaped by all this stuff that
you're watching online
you get a little bit older and you
realize that it was shaped in this way
and misshaped by it then that's when you
could start to recover but but it does
it does have an effect
that to a certain extent i mean you know
i just said a second ago that it's not
permanent i think in fact some of the
damage actually is permanent
it won't it doesn't doom you to uh to a
dysfunctional
sex life or dysfunctional relationships
your whole life but it is there are
there is some permanent damage done
because of what these kids are being
exposed to how early they're being
exposed to it how much of it they're
exposed to how often
and so if you listen to the kids who are
not you know not kids now they're adults
but if you just listen to them
so many of them will say exactly this i
grew up with this
and i wish that i hadn't
you you
you'd be hard-pressed to find someone
who's 20 years old right now
and is happy
that they've been watching hardcore porn
since the age of eight years old you're
gonna you're gonna you'll be
hard-pressed to find somebody like that
you might you're gonna find plenty of
people who have not had this awakening
moment that billy eilish has where they
realize the damage that's done
but if you ask them if this you know if
they look back at their childhood their
life is has this helped them was that
time well spent do they wish they had
watched even more i think the answer to
all those questions is going to be no
so this is very very different from the
magazine under the mattress deal
um these are kids that are exposed to
the most i mean the most
grotesque
imagery that you can imagine
like images right from the bowels of
hell that have been brought up and
bubbled up and that our kids are now
their minds are marinating in
for years and years and years
does that cause uh trauma yeah it does
and if you don't believe that then think
about i mean
if you heard about a case of sexual
abuse
where a ten-year-old kid a nine-year-old
kid
was allowed to be in the room
while
something like what you would see in
porn was happening right in front of
them
okay
we would all agree that that is sexual
abuse that this is a that that child is
a sexual abuse victim
this is a that he was molested even if
he wasn't physically touched he is a
victim of sexual abuse and molestation i
think we all agree with that i would
hope we'd all agree with that and that
the adults who were performing this
sexual act in front of the child
should go to prison
as sexual abusers
well if we could all agree that that is
traumatic sexual abuse
then how is it any different when the
kid is viewing this stuff on a screen
does that magically make
make it all okay does that does it does
that screen act as some sort of
psychological or emotional barrier
where the damage that would be done if
they were in the same room isn't done
anyway it doesn't make any sense
if you agree that simply encountering
those images
and viewing an
act like this at that age if you agree
that that it can be
emotionally and psychologically
traumatic and damaging and and
tantamount to sexual abuse
if you agree that that's the case in
person then you should agree with that
in uh when it comes to pornography which
means
that we have an entire generation and
now multiple generations
of sexual abuse victims
like all of these kids
are sexual abuse victims
because of what they've been exposed to
that's also why i think that's also why
i think you may you could make a very
strong argument for banning this stuff
because it is sexual abuse you're
putting this stuff out there
where you know that kids not only can
access it but millions of them are
every single day and you are
purposefully
making a contribution to that
contributing to the sexual abuse of
children i think you could ban it on for
that reason alone
that's my view
okay let's get down to the comment
section
[Music]
you know for a lot of people in your
home the garage is where you come and go
it's the most it's one of the more
active places in your house you're
walking through to enter it's it's one
of the most common entry points for a
home lots of things happen in garages
as we've just discussed with bubba
wallace and that's why it's great to
introduce the myq smart camera by
chamberlain if only bubble walls had had
a myq smart camera by chamberlain in his
garage we could have avoided so much
heartache the only smart camera
optimized for the garage brought to you
by the leaders in garage door opener
technology pair with the myq smart
garage control and you'll never have to
worry if you left the garage open you
can check it see it and close it all
from the my q app from anywhere
gives you a lot of abilities again
opening and closing the door and you can
let people into your home through this
through this app
and there's also motion detection and
all kinds of different things so so it's
all about security and convenience as
well so what are you waiting for give
the gift of a myq smart garage garage
camera to tech lovers this season if you
act now you can save 46 for a limited
time by entering walsh at checkout on
myq dot com walsh that's walsh checkout
at myq dot com walsh to say 46 keep an
eye on what's happening in and around
your home's busiest entryway with the
myq smart garage camera it's the only
smart camera optimized for the garage
susan epp says i urge everyone to read
gifted hands by ben carson he says he
frequently was mistaken for an aide or
orderly and orderly and that's fine
because they're important members of the
surgical and hospital staff
he addresses it so gracefully
well
ben carson no surprise there i think a
better man than dr smilet from our daily
cancellation a few days ago
alex sandra says matt death penalty
question after the written house trial
an interesting point was made on tim
poole's show that since we were this
close to sending an innocent kid to jail
for political reasons
how can we trust the state to properly
decide who they're going to kill it made
me think and i actually decided that my
distrust in the state political
establishment is so deep that i could no
longer support the death penalty
especially with current tyrannical
practices around the world what do you
think
you know i understand that argument but
i don't find it persuasive for a few
reasons i'll focus on one which is that
you know why aren't you arguing arguing
against
life in prison without parole i mean by
that by that logic
then we shouldn't be doling out any
punishments at all
you know there's there's a chance that
the state could send people to prison
for their whole lives lock them in a
cage
even if they're innocent
and i'm sure that has in fact happened
i don't think it happens very often
but i think we could be pretty sure that
there have been cases of of someone
going to jail spending 60 years in jail
locked in a cage although they're
innocent then they they die in jail
so in order in order to avoid that risk
and that eventuality should we get rid
of
life sentences or prison sentences in
general
um no i don't think the answer is to
do away with these punishments and these
penalties which i think you need in a
civilized society
we're not going to give up on having a
civilized society we're not going to
give up on justice
that's the other thing
this is not just about it's partly about
segregating dangerous people
life in prison you're segregating
dangerous people from society
and then when it comes to the most
depraved and the most dangerous people
who've done the worst kinds of things
and whoever do who have been reduced
reduced themselves to monsters to
animals basically through their behavior
i think they call for for this for the
safety of society
uh for
you know
for the sake of society i think they
call for the ultimate form of
segregation from society which is the
permanent you know death penalty that's
part of it but the other part is justice
and are we going to give up on that
i think when you when you do certain
things
a man rapes and kills a child
justice demands the death penalty
anything less than that is not justice
and so the argument here is well let's
give up on that because sometimes
justice is is is not done correctly
sometimes there is injustice in the name
of justice sometimes justice is
misapplied or you know
i think the answer is just to work on
the justice system make sure it's done
correctly
um
lex says you mentioned again today
abolishing the department of education
do you want to abolish the whole public
school system too what would take its
place do you really think we can
privatize all of education
well yes to all those questions but with
a very important qualifier
so when it comes to education like most
things in life
uh i'm a believer in subsidiary and that
means that that it should be handled on
the most local level possible so i want
education to be private
and local and the local part is really
important sometimes that gets left out
of this conversation
now the most the most localized form of
private education is home school it's
also the most private form of private
education and that's why i think it's
great and i'm a homeschool advocate
but i am in favor of local private
schools also
the local part is very important and
here's why
if in my fantasy
the public education was abolished
tomorrow and it doesn't exist anymore
department of education is gone public
education system is gone government is
out of the education business
if that would happen tomorrow and that
was it
and there were there was nothing else
put in place and and you know all we
cared about was let's just get rid of
this
and anything is better than that
well you know what we would have next
the next week
there would be amazon elementary you
know coca-cola middle school um disney
high right these mega conglomerates
would move in and they would take over
education
and all the things that we hate about
public education right now would be
would would be present in fact probably
be even worse
because at least with public education
there is the pretense the hope at least
that you can have some influence um on
what happens in the school system
through the school board and so on and
we've seen that actually happen
successfully especially recently but
with privatized conglomerate education
there isn't even the possibility of that
so um
so that's why
i have this really important qualifier
yes i'm in favor of getting rid of the
public education system but what what
comes in its place must be local and
private
one of my problems with with public
school education is that it is not local
so you're taking this thing which should
by its nature be as local as it possibly
can be and as personalized as it
possibly can be and you're turning it
into this kind of factory assembly line
strategy
and you've got this federal
agency overseeing all of it that's the
wrong way to approach it
and i would not be in favor of getting
rid of this massive bureaucracy
overseeing education just to put a
different one in its place
and this is this is something i think
conservatives in general are slow to
understand uh that big corporations are
oftentimes just as bad as the government
sometimes worse
because they are large
politicized bureaucracies run by elites
just like the government
all right um
and uh let's see gianna says why is
eureka o'hara always making his way onto
the matt walsh show
he was also the drag queen of the dave
chappelle protest outside the netflix
office okay i thought i recognized him
yeah so the drag queen from our daily
cancellation yesterday uh the the large
one the ursula looking one
yeah i thought he he was at the the dave
chappelle protest
i usually remember faces unless i
consciously try to suppress them from my
own mental well-being which i might have
done here
um
i don't know maybe drag queen eureka
o'hara is becoming the primary
antagonist of the matt wall show there's
always someone
right as we go through the seasons of
this show there's always a main villain
and i think prior to this it was
probably demi lovato
and before it was like maybe lil nas x
and uh and now it's eureka o'hara the
final boss
not only was the daily wire first in the
nation to sue the buying administration
for their unconstitutional mandate but
we're getting closer to a million
signatures on our do not comply petition
every single day why well because people
are realizing that if we don't actively
fight for our freedom the government
will take it we have a goal of reaching
one million signatures which would
provide a major boost to our legal
challenge we have over 875 000
signatures so far so we're going to get
there but let's get there as soon as we
possibly can help us cross the finish
line go to dailywire.com do not comply
and sign the position today now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we have a reverse cancellation not
in my own defense but in defense of ben
shapiro's sister abby um i'm doing this
segment today because ben said we all
had to do it or we'd be fired but mostly
i'm doing it because abby is being
unfairly maligned for something she said
on twitter a few days ago she has a nice
social media following of her own she
posted a side-by-side picture of madonna
and nancy reagan
madonna is this is a picture from
madonna this is a picture from a few
days ago she spread out on a bed in
lingerie with her nipple poking out a
heavily photoshopped image by the way to
the point where this is more of a
cartoon than a photograph
and then nancy reagan in the picture
taken decades ago is dressed in an
outfit appropriate for a woman her age
and surrounded by her children
grandchildren or husband and abby
captions this is madonna at 63 this is
nancy rogan at 64. trashy living versus
classic living
which version of yourself do you want to
be
now the reaction perhaps predictably was
interruption of outsized
hyperbolic rage and mockery from the
left abby was trending on twitter for a
few days because so many people were
lining up
to dunk on this tweet as the kids would
say
it was supposed to be somehow not only
wrong but self-evidently outrageous to
suggest that perhaps it's not ideal for
63-year-old women to be presenting their
naked bodies to the public for attention
but as always
the people pretending to be wounded or
vexed by this statement are simply
trying to rationalize their own life
choices it is one enormous act of
overcompensation
now if madonna wanted to dress that way
for for her husband
there'd be no reason for complaint i
mean none of us would know about it
so no reason for us to complain
no reason for her husband to complain i
imagine
but i'm pretty sure madonna doesn't have
a husband because she divorced all of
them and she's now dating the pool boy
or whoever
and so this is not something done in the
privacy of her home but broadcast to the
world for public consumption
it is pathetic and humiliating and
degrading for a person of any age to
offer up their body as an object to
strangers but it's especially pitiful
for a woman of madonna's age
that you know there's a certain dignity
that's supposed to come with age
and it's good to gain dignity with age
because it takes the place of what you
lose
and you do lose some things with age
namely you lose a certain degree of
physical beauty and vitality
so this is the bargain that our
mortality makes with us it says to us
okay i'm going to take your beauty and
your youthful energy
but i'll trade you
wisdom maturity and dignity
so that's what you get
and you may as well take mortality up on
this bargain because it's going to
extract its cost regardless
even if you say uh
no thank you i'm not interested in your
wisdom and dignity which is what madonna
has said
well still mortality says well but i'm
taking youthfulness anyway and i'm
taking beauty
and yeah you you know you're gonna be
left with plastic surgery and photoshop
and so now women like madonna are just
old wrinkled desperate dumb immature
weirdos
in madonna's case she she has had
attention her whole life she's been
famous way longer than she was a normal
person she defines herself by attention
and fame but unfortunately she lacks the
ability to attract it artistically
she hasn't made a relevant song in about
30 years probably so this is all she has
her half-naked body
it's the only way to gain the spotlight
that she craves and that she needs
contrast that with nancy reagan as
depicted in the photo and you see an
older woman who has grown into her role
as an older woman embraced it accepted
mortality's bargain
and benefited from the trade
so which version of ourselves should we
want to be i mean i think that's pretty
obvious
in fact it's interesting to note that
abby is not alone in making this point
the rapper 50 cent who um probably does
not line up with the shapiro family very
often when it comes to political and
cultural views
actually made a similar observation in
his own way commenting on these photos
when they were posted to instagram 50
cent said yo this is the funniest lol
that's madonna under the bed trying to
do like a virgin at 63.
she shot out if she don't get her old
ass up
so that's basically what bench peer
sister was trying to say and you could
decide who communicated the point more
eloquently as it happens madonna's
response to 50 cent's comments she
responded calling them misogynistic
ageist and sexist
so she's playing the standard game of
parading her naked body around in front
of millions of strangers and then
recoiling in horror when a few of those
strangers dare to express their opinion
about the spectacle
but she has no room to complain
if she didn't want to hear 50 cent's
opinion about her appearance as she lays
naked on a bed
then she shouldn't have went through the
trouble of documenting herself in that
condition and posting it on social media
for millions of people to see once you
present something like that to the world
once you present anything to the world
once you take anything and say here you
go world look at this
the world has a right to pass its
judgment
if you really don't want to hear the
world's judgment
or you think the world has no right to
make such judgments
then keep it to yourself
that goes for your naked body it goes
for your opinions
if you express an opinion to the world i
do it all the time
hey world here's my opinion about this
and if people attack me for it i might
respond to those attacks i might hit
back but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna say
you're crying that they disagree
how dare you give your opinion about my
opinion
but madonna understands this but this is
the game she plays it's a pretty common
game especially in the internet age but
usually it's played by people who are
young and dumb and who struggle to
differentiate between what should be
private and what should be public
but donna is old
and still struggling in that way
mainly because she never formed any sort
of real personal identity outside of her
role as celebrity
that's what makes this sort of
exhibition so woefully depressing
because it's empty i mean this is an
empty person grasping out for attention
because it's the one thing that gives
her life meaning
by her age she ought to have a full life
deeply moored in family and
relationships as nancy reagan clearly
had at that point in her own life
so which fate would you rather share
do you want to be the woman less than a
decade away from turning 70 prostituting
yourself with images photoshopped to
make you look 50 years younger
or do you want to be surrounded by
family and by love and by loyalty
and to leave behind a real legacy
i think we all know which we would
prefer
that's the point abby was making
and she could not have been more right
about it which is why the people
canceling her
are today finally cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
buy my book at johnnywalrus.com godspeed
[Music]
somewhere
past the pandemic
when we're
free
there's a
i remember
full of activity
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2021.
today on the ben shapiro show the white
house announces that joe biden will
commemorate january 6th as the
congressional commission focuses on mark
meadows text messages that's today on
the bench bureau show give it a listen